I think this actually is creating more
of a complex because back when a girl
just was a girl who happened to be a
tumbler she said she's a girl she just
likes baseball
yeah tomorrow are you trans what do you
want you want to shoot your up your
vagina and put on a mechanical fist no
no I just I just like to climb trees
just like Barry Bonds when did this
happen why do you think the left right
now is so obsessed with applying the
progressive gender ideology to children
we've talked about transitioning
children before in the past on a
personal level just parents who do it
but it is kind of the cause at large
right now I have my theory on that let
me know if you notice it why you think
that is today we are addressing
rebutting this video this this package I
guess in a program raising
gender-neutral babies was I think their
title and this is of course the latest
cause that we've been talking about
let's uh do we have a clip let's roll
the first clip I warn you this is very
disturbing to a lot of people but
instead of a boy or a girl
gender-neutral babies are known as
babies babies are babies without a known
sex that means only parents and trusted
caregivers know that baby's Anatomy they
say the gender part comes later and is
left up to the child what if it's a [ __ ]
what's it it's a baby with rabies
maybe he has scabies tell me baby here's
the thing how many tips do you think
that took with putting the balloon in
this is one thing to I would like to
know Silicon Valley Twitter Facebook
YouTube will have these rules where we
have to talk about gender and separate
gender from sex birth
they just said babies without a known
sex how do you expect us to play by
rules that you can't possibly even
follow because it's made-up sex and
gender have always been the same thing
gender was a grammatical term largely
until very recently and this is a think
gender-neutral parent thing it used to
mean that you didn't force your children
to play with Tonka trucks or your girls
to play with Barbies I'll do both of
those things by the way
as soon as my boy comes out he's getting
a Schlitz in one hand and a Tonka truck
in the other grandchildren but now that
y-you think and this is I want to get to
all the details here because it's very
disturbing the only thing that if a girl
is it is a tomboy and she plays sports
with her dad that she's transgender now
right now yeah and this is in order to
be more sensitive I think this actually
is creating more of a complex because
back when a girl just was a girl who
happened to be a tomboy she said she's a
girl she just likes baseball
yeah so are you trans what do you want
you want to suture up your vagina and
put on a mechanical fist no no I just I
just like to climb trees just like Barry
Bonds okay same thing of a boy is
sensitive you know a boy needs to be
sensitive it's a little hose on you
wanna you want to cut off your penis no
no no I just I just I just like rom-coms
something because I watched them with
mom I think I'm trying to be more
sensitive these people are creating an
atmosphere where people are going to be
there you have more societal pressure on
them yeah they're people are trying to
raise these kids in a completely
genderless environment and and they're
hiding it will go from others and that
creates some discomfort and it forces
the child we'll get into this they're
now forcing the children into this sort
of non-binary they realm of pronouns and
there's an area here that's lost let's
let's go to it the gender reveal
won't happen anytime soon we did not
assign a sex at birth which means when
they sign they had genitals and we know
what they are we just chose to
acknowledge that those genitals don't
indicate anything about generally ok
chose to acknowledge first off no sex at
birth
I thought gender was separate from sex
I'm so confused again the sex isn't
Polly we're told that sex is biological
right and gender is how you identify
well right now they've just said sex the
first lady who's for introducing this
package at whatever his local affiliate
Burlington Vermont I have no idea vivia
said sex and they're gonna go back to
that with a birth certificate we just
chose not to acknowledge the sex no you
chose not to acknowledge the sex okay
what about doctors yeah
what about anyone involves with modern
medicine or
all that we have come to know up to the
year 2020 involving biological sciences
think what are you do you going to a
doctor you go hey is my kid healthy well
I think he's healthy enough well let me
take a look what's your what's your
child's weight 85 pounds well okay your
daughter I'm sure that's fine what's the
height right well what should be the
size of the cranium we I think we have
an overlay here you can look at these
charts they are all dependent on a
child's sex anyone who has a dog knows
that I have been Betty is on average 15
to 20 pounds lighter than hopper for the
breed standard right what does a doctor
do risk hate-speech because you chose to
not acknowledge the sex your words not
mine
and by the way outside of the realm of
Medicine even the preference for certain
toys with young children based on innate
sexual characteristics not just social
norms the greatest indicator that we
have of young people children boys and
girls as to how their behavioral
patterns will manifest themselves not
only not only themselves but in their
interactions with other people is their
genitals is their biological sex
especially before you introduce language
into the mix of this there can be no
debate let's go to the next your next
question might be is Sparrow a boy or
girl
Nico will be answer to be determined did
not know sparrows genitals for the first
three months even though what she was
living with us at the time the custom on
Julie's sparrows parents decided so was
their baby gender-neutral names Sparrow
will decide gender when older even
sparrows birth certificate says sex
unknown first off my mother didn't know
and she lived in the house for what are
you trying to pull a trick are you
playing cups and the birthday she won't
determine her gender till later even her
birth certificate says sex unknown no
you
interchangeable and this is what the
truth they train walk backwards and lay
down set bear traps for you where you go
for a second you can't change your
biologicals that's why I don't believe
into any battle our sense is about
gender there two are separate but you
put unknown on the birth certificate for
sex let me go create some Community
Guidelines so you're banned for even
talking about sex I would wager this is
far harder than just being I can't say
mmm I'm not allowed to say well we'll
have to bleep that soft bleep some
people Gunderson's rather than doing it
fully or let's just go with their
traditional way yeah your mother lived
in the house for three months had no
idea when she she never changed a diaper
no was she doing there
it seems very seems very abrasive child
that's what you weren't going to such
extreme measures to hide the child's sex
from other people I mean anyone who's
ever had a child you're looking to storm
out of that bedroom naked at some point
exactly
it's just gonna happen one of those
houses you didn't even know really well
what length did you go to try and
disguise that sorry gender sex whatever
term you're using that day as long as
you want to score points on me in a
debate to avoid logic what lengths did
you go to because guess what that's
gonna be offloaded onto your child
they're going to see that as they grow a
little bit older all right let's go to
the next clip we are in no way
prohibiting Sparrow from having a gender
is work and we're not forcing them to be
one gender or another actually
interesting interesting you should bring
that up because in the realm of this is
where it there is no consistency because
I think Facebook is it up to 57 genders
now 153 they added some here's the thing
these are definitive genders yeah we are
just told that mmm there are multitude
of genders or I don't fit into the
binary that's not where this has ended
they've gone into creating specific
gender categories that never existed
until for some reason 2018 right we
figured it out yeah just don't tell the
doctors and they've prosperous for our
own good and this is important because
they identifying as they it's it's own
thing the left has said the progressive
left they've been emphatic that a they
slashed them pronoun is it's all
exclusive non-binary identity and that
it reflects how someone feels on the
inside so it's not that they is a
general catch-all for people who don't
identify as male or female that is one
of the 50-something genders right lest
you think I make I'm making this up
let's go to the clip of them being very
clear in these new instructions when
someone identifies or the pronoun
they're essentially taking their little
piece of that broad universe and
identifying with that and so in using
their correct pronouns we're validating
that yes you are right in your identity
and you are important for more context
in there in that original tip she's
talking about they yeah so what do you
do now if you don't know like if you're
if you're trying to be even woke er well
that's a good question because by that
logic forcing your child to be of a them
how how is that any more valid than
raising them as a he or she
right right all right what is this
concept of forcing your child you sort
of abuse you're not forcing your child
to do anything this is another thing
when people talk about spankings or
disciplinary action I don't want to get
into whether you're you're pro spanking
or not pro spank that people go what are
you spank an adult I also wouldn't tell
an adult to go to his room it's not an
appropriate analogy I wouldn't tell an
adult to stop playing in his own I
wouldn't stop pulling on his balls like
it's a door knocker from Young
Frankenstein but I have to do it with my
nephew it's not a valid are you forcing
your child to grow up in your house are
you forcing them not to live in their
own filth
are you forcing them to not watch
r-rated films and by the way the only
people who identify with these these
pronouns like they it still is only the
trans community yeah very exclusive so
this is we need to be important we need
to be purposeful about this one you say
I'm not gonna force my child to be a he
or a she but I'm okay forcing them to be
Ave by your own rules and I know your
rules are a little bit murky with the
sex and gender being interchangeable
here but let's try and apply some
consistency so by your own rules they
them is its own exclusive gender
category you don't want to force them
into he or she but you want to force
them into the they then category which
is a category and is exclusive to the
transgender community effectively you've
decided to force your child into the
category with a demographic of a 42%
attempted suicide rate yeah
by the way pre or post up if you could
avoid that in any other instance and say
well hole second I don't want to I want
to give my kid the best leg up that's
why you send them to school that's why
you try and make sure that they have
extracurricular activities that's why
you try to make sure that you give them
their Flintstone vitamins right you want
what's best for them if you could avoid
a 42% suicide rate well the vast
majority ninety something percent of
kids who even identify as trans before
they're told that they're non-binary
from their parents grow out of it so
guess what you're just being
irresponsible by forcing this upon your
children you are forcing this upon your
children says nothing to do with people
who are choosing to identify as trans as
adults you are forcing your children
into a category that comes with it
statistical risks that don't exist in
the he or she next clip we didn't want
Sparrow to grow up in an environment
devoid of gender we want that's not real
yeah it's not real life we want them to
get to experience all genders seems to
me you're the expert real life like a
boy and then getting getting treated
like someone you can't tell shows them
what the diverse options are I'm so glad
you are the expert on this subject
rachel maddow and your nose-ring and I
love Lisa so much so just imagine this
of being raises everyone just constantly
being confused as to what gender you are
what do you think is going to do to the
child's sense of identity I always have
to have a conversation and by the way
you are choosing to make them have a
conversation they now try to teach them
just this is just simple if everyone
asks everybody's gender pronouns you
know to whom that would be most
devastating we're talking about people
we care about in sympathy it would be
most devastating toward larger women
think about this for a second next time
you see a large doesn't have to be if
that woman at all broad shouldered woman
ask her her preferred gender pronouns
and duck very quickly you would
devastate them it is far more rude to
ask
everybody's gender pronouns because
that's not how we interact the society
will never be how we interact as a
society you are trying to make everybody
uncomfortable and make everybody have to
deal with borderline sociopathic
behavior devoid of empathy because you
want to accommodate less than 1% of the
population and by accommodate I mean
force them
to the scenario when they're children
because they don't have a choice in the
matter you're dumping endless confusion
on them just so you can claim most woke
parent alright next clip now what if
sparrow says to you in the coming years
and my boy or girl I would tell them
that they're the only one who gets to
decide that that I can't know that well
do you feel like a boy do you feel like
a girl so you've now just taught your
child to not go to mom or dad for
answers all it takes is one parent to
apply this to their child no chalica
mundos hey and it's just a trick and
they'll set you up my a boy or a girl
only you can know that boy thanks mom
guess don't oh you're gonna set a curfew
don't wait up okay I don't necessarily
respect the authority of these
boundaries if you can't tell what's
hanging between my legs
mom identify somebody you can stay up to
whatever the hell they want right
exactly but you know what mom you're
right only I can make that decision blow
your nose in rejecting all these norms
from society you just these people
you're raising your children to have no
sense of normalcy or security that's the
opposite of what a parent should do
parents should have answers for their
children with these questions that is
part of your job as a parent it's the
unwritten contract that you sign all
right next clip there's no way this can
go wrong people will be like oh really
okay you can think of you this one age
well if gender is really something in
you then no one's gonna change that okay
one caveat the one potential wrinkle and
by one potential wrinkle I mean this
thing looks like a shar-pei might be
that let's say that 99% of all the
information that we have right that is
based on the idea of gender being bodge
a lot of biological and not some vague
innate feeling if we accept that
everything we've known about gender sex
interchangeable as you've made very
clear before that everyone else before
you woke
had it right ooh that means you have
everything wrong so that's just one
wrinkle if you're starting off point
might be slightly incorrect
never mind by the way let's go to the
starting off point that you are are
typically using for this pioneers of
gender we've talked about John money he
tried doing this what could possibly go
wrong he tried raising twins this is the
famous twin experiment one as a boy
david rhymer I believe was it David I
can't remember the exact we have an
overlay one boy money raises a boy one
you ended up raising as a girl yeah the
boy ended up rejecting the identity
later committed suicide I believe that
both ultimately ended up committing
suicide if I'm not mistaken the point is
the founder of your feast you say what
could go wrong it went wrong immediately
the starting point went wrong your
pioneer went wrong and here is the
problem the entire premise of the left
sin since insistence on using certain
pronouns is that it supposedly changes
how you view yourself right and so
therefore changes your identity now it's
so important to them that they've made
laws about it going so far as fining
people who would dare use the wrong
pronouns which are changing every single
day so if a pronoun has such a profound
effect on someone why have you decided
to burden your children with these
non-binary pronouns you are the one who
you're still choosing pronouns you're
choosing them day yeah and you've made
it very good natural in it there's a
specific there is no neutral you are
choosing to burden them with something
that you have deemed to be incredibly
important it just changes depending on
your definition from day to day and if
gender is really socially constructed as
leftist argue that's well I think it's
important because we can argue about it
Phil and we have done this before
I would say when we started the show we
were arguing about this philosophically
and what kind of societal ramifications
they could have if we completely
eliminated the idea of gender lines or
norms but this is now a very real very
tangible application it's in process in
the most innocent among us the most
vulnerable among us yes children I think
so let's go is if gender is socially
constructed as you say and it's the most
powerful shaping force in societies they
try to make it out to be to the point
where they want their birth certificates
to read your guess is as good as mine
right unclear then that means it's
really important how your mother gender
and your dad dad gender raised you oh
wait a second where's the debt hmm go
watch this video tell me if you see one
if we're talking about important gender
is okay I'll go with that
I believe that gender and sex are
important I believe in every single
statistical reality that we have
reflects this that a child does best and
requires a mother and a father a mother
and a father because yes gender does
determine that people are singularly
unique with attributes as well as
shortcomings mothers and fathers where's
the dad if we're talking about what's
best for the child where is the debt and
this is what this is where all of this
stems from okay I think this is
important for people to note it's a
dad's job to stop this kind of stuff
typically speaking we're talking with
the gender roles right mom is supposed
to be more nurturing more loving more
empathetic they listen to your feelings
dad is the one who is supposed to be
pragmatic dad is the one who tells you
to stop cut it out
don't make me come back there mom is the
one who says well can't we get him this
toy and dad says money doesn't grow on
trees these are the traditional roles
that we're talking I'm not talking about
a dad smacking you around or not telling
you that he loves you he won't hug you
that's not what I'm saying not some
false sense of machismo but their
appropriate roles gendered roles for
mothers and fathers in the home and
we've decided for some reason now that
one gender is completely limited I'll
tell you where this starts from this
really bothers me
it comes from I'm not saying the gay
agenda that's what I'm saying but the
radical gay left I'm talking with the
Folsom Street Fair this type of stuff
where we talked about we've talked about
this before this is the first society in
a history of ever to have men getting
married and that was a start what we
said kids don't need a mom and dad yeah
two dads exact same thing I'm not saying
that a kid who's in a foster home or
who's in in it Oliver Twist wouldn't
have done better with two dads who like
to do interior decoration of course he
would but I am saying that in the ideal
scenario we should aim for a mother and
a father because they both provide
something singularly unique to that
child that the other can not and this
came with
the idea of two dads just as good two
moms this is good but before this is one
thing I want people to understand before
we get this whole idea of the gay agenda
that people often bring up that's not
where it started you know where this
started I act is it's a Seidel issue I'm
using a specific example to make a point
so don't think I'd have some vendetta
against Jennifer Aniston stopped
watching friends when Rachel unfriend
said I want to have a kid and Ross who I
believe if not mistaken was the father
and she's saying no it was a one-night
stand I don't want you in this child's
life and this we praise this woman
society oh look Jennifer and Rachel's
having a child now was no dad because
she's a strong independent woman guess
who's not going to be strong and
independent that child
statistically more likely to end up in
prison less likely to graduate high
school less likely to get married to
have healthy relationships of their own
more likely to have mental illness of
any kind it started with this idea that
it's somehow virtuous to eliminate any
of the gendered roles in the home
usually it starts with vilifying the
father because as some kind of a a
resistance to the form of an idea of a
patriarchal household we tried to make
sure that we told dads you're not all
that important in society look the most
popular girl the most highly paid woman
in all of sitcom television can raise a
baby without a father who even wants to
be in the child's life but we don't need
them and then you know what happened
there men absolve themselves of being
fathers well how's that working out for
you I mean do you think that Ben are
better today than they were 20 years ago
you feel like it's easier to find a
virtuous man who will hold the door for
you this is what it comes down to
fathers matter mothers matter why
because sex is biological it is innate
and you can't choose it and you
certainly can't choose it for your child
and then when your child comes back and
asks you what gender they are saying I
don't know what do you think it's no way
to raise a child it's no way to run a
society
you like this video click one of these
other videos playing in a box up there
and hit subscribe or the notification
bell if you're already subscribed so you
can find out about our new
non-controversial videos which don't
ruffle any feathers and of course are
not a violation of YouTube's algorithms
everyone's welcome here except oh I
don't know if we are but it's our
channel not sure how that works